-Our first guests tonight
are Tony Award-winning actors
who currently star in
"The Music Man,"
which is playing at the Winter
Garden Theatre on Broadway.
Please welcome back to the show
Sutton Foster
and Hugh Jackman, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome! It's so lovely
to have both of you here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was -- I was lucky enough
to see this incredible musical
on opening night.
There was such enthusiasm
because it's also --
It's a show, it's Broadway.
It's people being
back out together again.
Is that energy the same
every night?
Because it was tremendous
the first night out.
-It really has been.
I mean, Broadway was nonexistent
for almost two years.
And I feel like there's this
shared sense of gratitude
between the people on stage
and the audience.
And the show is so joyful,
and I'm having
the time of my life
playing opposite this guy.
-You had to say that,
but thank you.
-I did!
But it's really like --
It's like --
It's a dream come true.
-Can you guys clock
what kind of audience
you have on any given night?
I mean, you obviously have a lot
of two-person scenes
in the show.
Can you make eye contact and
know it's this kind of night?
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-There's a couple of things.
So I'm on stage --
Sutton's not on stage
at the beginning,
but I'm on stage
behind the thing.
And so sometimes you can hear
clapping along with the overture
and we have a little signal,
we can tell,
but sometimes the audience
goes -- [Whistles] way off.
Like, hecklers.
-Oh, yeah, we did have --
-What kind of heckles do you
get during "The Music Man"?
[ Laughter ]
-Good point.
Mainly -- Mainly clean.
-Yeah, yeah.
-"Kiss her already!"
-Oh, a lot "kiss her already"?
-Yeah.
-You do make us wait for it
a bit in the show.
-Yeah, we do.
-We once got a, "Hey-oh!"
Yeah, that was --
I'm not encouraging heckling.
-Yeah, yeah. Right. Exactly.
-I did -- I stand up
at the beginning of the show,
I say one line, and I stand up
and I did hear a "Wolverine!"
And I'm like...
"It's gonna be a long night,
pal, I'm just sayin'."
-And they're like,
"He's not wolverine."
-There's not much
of that coming. -Yeah.
He's, like -- The whole show
is about a con man.
That might be the twist at
the end, that it was Wolverine.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
-"Music Man Deux."
-But we did have
a hilarious sneezer.
-Oh, no.
-Yeah, it was like --
Someone with
a really bad allergy
who probably also
is a stand-up comedian
because the timing was perfect
on every sneeze.
-Perfect timing.
And then this one --
We're in the second act.
We have a very long scene
together where we're like,
you know,
breaking down and starting to,
like, fall for each other,
and this person
is sneezing repeatedly.
And then at one point he went,
"Bless you."
And I was like, "Oh,"
and then it was over.
And then he exits
and just leaves me
on stage to have to
endure the wrath.
-At which point, as I walked
out, Sutton goes, "Terrific."
-"Great."
-"Never working with you again.
This is great."
-I mean, again, there are all
these tremendous moments,
but -- and beautiful songs.
But speaking of live theater,
there's a scene in a library
where you have so many dancers
and it's just the amount
of choreographed book throwing.
And, I mean,
I was there opening night.
I did not see a book fall.
Do books ever fall?
-We were good on opening night.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-But I actually gave a hard hat
to the conductor
because I nearly clocked him
about three nights ago.
-Really?
-I threw it up, and I lost it
in the light,
and I'm like, "Uh-oh."
And I -- But I missed it.
And it was literally -- whoom!
But we have a musical --
Patrick Vaccariello
has got incredible timing
because it just went -- wheeoop!
-Oh, he hit it back up!
-It was pretty great.
-Have you ever, either of you,
personally been hit with a book?
-Oh, I have, yeah.
I've got pelted in the head.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-Wow.
-They fly all over the place!
Then one night it kind of, like,
bounced and it went, ga-goink,
and I was like, "Okay."
-So you -- I know you guys
had met over the years.
Obviously, this is the first
time you're working together.
I would imagine you each have
a different reason
to be intimidated going into
rehearsals with one another.
Was -- Did that exist
for each of you?
I mean --
-Yes.
-Yes, very much so.
I was -- Yes, yes.
I mean, you're -- Yes.
You're Hugh Jackman.
-So they told you right away
he was Hugh Jackman?
-Yeah, they said,
"It's Hugh Jackman."
And then it's, like, our names
are, like, really big
on, like, a giant billboard.
And I was like, "Oh, God, that's
gonna cost a lot of money
when they have to replace me."
Because I'm like,
"That's real big.
It's a lot of paint."
But I was pretty convinced
I was going to be fired
for several weeks.
-Oh, stop it.
-It's true, though, you know?
You just get -- But I guess,
like, I don't know,
that's part of the reason
why you do what you do.
If you were like,
"Oh, yeah, I got this."
-But that's a big --
Has it always been that way?
I mean, you know, I know you did
"Boy from Oz" in 2004.
I imagine
in everything you've done,
I imagine the early days
of the rehearsal,
you must always feel that, like,
"Oh, they're going to
pull the plug."
-And particularly
after the pandemic.
It'd been a while for anybody
being back in that room.
I was certainly intimidated.
This is a six-time Tony nominee.
-Yeah.
-Two-time winner.
Like, I saw her do
"Thoroughly Modern Millie"
when you were like 4 years old.
But I've watched everything
she's done. It's amazing.
And I'm the guy who,
in my first show,
"Beauty and the Beast,"
it was in my contract
that I had to have
singing lessons once a week.
So, you know, I --
[ Laughter ]
That's true, by the way.
It may be a professional first.
"Did you go this week?"
I'm like, "Yeah."
"Really?"
I was like, "yeah."
-Did your teacher have to, like,
sign a note for you?
-100%.
-That's really funny.
Well, it's paid off, Hugh,
because you're absolutely --
So you know what?
That was very unfair
that they made you do that,
but it was worth every penny.
We'll be right back.
I have more to ask you guys.
That's Sutton Foster and
Hugh Jackman. Stick around.